Scot Osterweil: turn the floor
over to Eric Klopfer who's going
to introduce today's speaker.
Eric Klopfer: Thanks, Scot. Um,
so I will briefly introduce
Justin, who's gonna be talking
today about "Failure to
Disrupt", his new book on
educational technology and its
failure to disrupt educational
practices. And Justin is a
professor here in Comparative
Media Studies and Writing. And
before that, he was a researcher
and lecturer here at MIT. So
he's been associated with the
community for for many years I'm
doing he taught my my education
courses previously, and and ran
our, our partnership with the
Woodrow Wilson Academy for a
number of years, Justin has been
doing work that I think I would
describe as sort of healthy
skepticism about educational
technologies, for I think, most
of his career, including his his
doctoral work and a lot of his
work more recently. And, you
know, it's it's sort of taking
this lens on educational
technology that's both sort of
hopeful and, and critical in
terms of looking at the ways
that it ultimately influences
the practices of educators, as
well as the lives of the many
students involved in the
educational systems. Justin runs
our Teaching Systems Lab here,
which looks at a lot of issues
in professional development of
teachers use implementation of
educational technologies, equity
in education, and innovative
practices for for training, both
current and next generations of
teachers. So with that, I will
hand it over to Justin, and
thanks for coming to colloquium
today, Justin.
Justin Reich: Thanks, Eric.
We have some great instructors,
writing instructors, who help us
teach the media studies classes
to undergraduates at MIT. And
they try to help Media Studies
undergraduates think about what
argumentation and Media Studies
looks like. And one of the ways
they describe it is to say that
there are producers of media,
and audiences of media and they
sort of interact in some way
through media in some kind of
broader social context. And
everything can get much more
complex than that. The producers
can become consumers, the
consumers, producers, all that
kind of stuff, but there, but
there's a kind of fundamental
structure to a lot of common
arguments. And I would say, a
lot of my work is interested in
that model as well. That there
are people who take and
facilitate media as educators,
and there are people who consume
that media as learners. And
sometimes they pass it back and
forth. In some kind of broader
context. You know, the thing
which distinguishes me as a
learning scientist from other
media studies scholars, is I
tend to be keenly interested in
how does that interaction change
human development? How does the
learner develop new capacities?
How are they able to do
different kinds of things than
they were before on the basis of
that interaction? And I'm hoping
that one of the things that can
come out of this conversation
is, is I'll present to you some
of the ways that I see the field
of education technology as a
learning scientist, and I hope
that folks will will ask
questions from a media studies
perspective and and make you
know, for the graduate students
make connections to the readings
and other kinds of things.
You're working on faculty, the
research and other practices
that you see are germane. And
we'll see if we can make some
some connections that way. So
one place that I start my work
is that for the last 20 years,
people have made some really
extraordinary claims about how
new media might transform the
education landscape. In 2009, a
Harvard Business School
Professor Clay Christensen
predicted that by 2019, last
year, half of all secondary
school courses in the United
States would be online or
blended, that they would cost a
third as much to provide and
they would produce better
learning outcomes. In 2012, when
Massive Open Online Courses
exploded in higher education,
edX and Coursera Udacity
Sebastian Thrun, the founder of
Udacity, said 50 years there's
only 10 institutions of higher
education left in the world.
They're going to be you know, a
concentrated set of mega
universities providing the
world's best learning content
all around the world and Udacity
might be one of them. Sal Khan
in 2011, Ted Talks said, Let's
use video to reinvent education,
let's have individual students
sit down in front of computers,
let's have a personalized
learning pathway around
mathematics for them that sort
of optimized for their
individual learning rate. And
we'll still have students and
teachers and things like that.
But they mostly get together
like to do interesting projects
and to, you know, reflect on
what they're learning and build
community, but the sort of heart
of skills development will
happen through these machines.
And then 2013, Sugata, Mitra won
the TED Prize for his proposal
that we didn't even need schools
or educational institutions
anymore, that we could simply
give kids laptops and broadband
connection. And without any
institutional support, they
could learn anything by
themselves. And then earlier
this year, the world was
blighted by a global pandemic
and 1.6 billion learners were
sent home. And to some extent,
you might think that like, this
was the moment that education
technology was poised for, I
mean, prior to the pandemic, the
case that education
technologists had to make was
that they had a set of offerings
that would be better than the
existing traditional educational
system. But they didn't even
have to make that claim anymore.
They simply had to claim that
they could offer better learning
experiences, then, you know,
pandemic hobbled system in the
middle of an emergency pivot to
remote teaching.
And I think during the last 20
years, one of the reasons why
the arguments of education
technologists, for the
transformative potential of
Learning Media was so powerful
is that we saw these
transformations happen in other
sectors. Journalism has been
profoundly reshaped by media,
government and civic media is in
the midst of a transformation.
The word friend means something
different than when I was
growing up dating our
relationships. I mean, some of
our most intimate experiences
are mediated by technology, by
social media in particular, in
new ways. Doesn't it stand to
reason that the same kind of
thing shouldn't happen in
education as well? Like, why
would education be a sector
that's different from any other
sector? But I think most of you
know what has happened during
the pandemic, which is that, you
know, education technology does
not right in on, you know, a
flaming horse to a winged horse
to save us all. In fact, I think
most people, most families,
especially younger children, but
I think many folks in higher
education and well have have
experienced something ranging
from like, this is adequate to
wow, this is really a disaster
for us and for our families. And
in fact, two of the technology,
I think the two most prominent
technologies of the pandemic are
two of the very oldest
technologies that we have. So so
I would argue that the two
technologies that have dominated
the pandemic are learning
management systems, which are
basically platforms that allow
people to pass documents back
and forth with one another thick
Canvas Schoology Google
Classroom. These were theorized
in the 60s and 70s. They were
commercialized in the 1990s,
they will made open source in
the 2000s. And then the other
you know, perhaps dominant
technology of the pandemic has
been what in the 1930s, when it
was introduced was called video
telephony now goes by the term
of video conferencing. And I
think what we saw both in higher
education and in K 12 education
was, you know, a series of
collective acts of conservatism,
small c conservatism, the likes
of which we will never again see
in our lifetime, faced with
dramatically changing
circumstances, you know, most of
the professor it like walked
away from their lecterns and sat
down in front of their home
office video cameras, and kept
teaching, you know, roughly the
same way that they were teaching
beforehand, despite all the
transformations happening in the
world, and despite the promises
of people that technology would
rearrange those relationships
even in normal times, let alone
pandemic times. So my task as a
writer in this book is to
explain why that is to explain
why these arguments of
transformation can be so
tractable at times can be so
compelling at times. But also
the argument is that they
shouldn't be so compelling
because they're routinely not
true, and that there are more
productive stances to take
towards the role of technology
in schools. Last year, before
the pandemic, Sal Khan gave an
interview to a little trade
magazine called this
administration. So I'm sure
millions of people have seen Sal
Khan's TED Talks, I promise you
that it was like me and four
other people who read this
interview. In district
administration magazine, it
turns out that in the last
decade, Sal Khan had not only
built Khan Academy, this library
of videos on instructional
topics, and an adaptive tutor
and other kinds of tools, but he
actually built a regular in
person school. As a private
school, I think it's in Silicon
Valley area, it costs 20 or
$25,000, a year to attend. And
his observation after working on
this project for a long time was
now that I run a school, I see
that some of this stuff is not
as easy to accomplish compared
to how it sounds theoretically.
And his new argument was that
actually a better way it was,
it's not going to be the case
that Khan Academy is going to
transform relationships in
schools, we are not going to
have students who are spending
all you know most of their time
developing skills through these
individual pathways. And at the
end of their skill development
coming together for rich,
intricate project based
learning. Instead, the model
that he's recommending is to
teach about the way you had been
teaching four days a week, and
then use Khan Academy his
practice problems one day a
week. And he says that's doable,
that's tractable. And it's also
has some benefits for students
math learning. Um, the thing
that struck me in a powerful way
about that argument was how
incredibly well established it
was. So you can go back to the
1990s. Here's an article from
1997, published by Ken Koedinger
at Carnegie Mellon University,
where they had done in the
Pittsburgh schools the exact
thing. They had built a series
of cognitive tutors, adaptive
tutors that responded to
students responses and gave them
progressively easier harder or
properly sequence math
challenges. And they told
teachers to use it three or four
days a week, I think they told
him to use it three days a week,
or they told him to use it one
to two days a week and teach in
a regular way, three or four
days a week. And they ended up
for the most part if they use it
using it one day a week. And
they found the same kinds of
things that Sal Khan found 25
years later, which is that if
you have people teach in a
regular way, four days a week,
and then use adaptive tutors as
practice problems one day a
week, it works a little better
than what had come before. You
know, another way to frame this
is that, you know, kind of
Academy I think, is raised like
100 and $50 million in
philanthropic support over the
last eight or nine years. And
you know, what they what they
learned from that investment,
you could have discovered with
it with a trip to the library.
So,
when I contrast Sal Khan of 2011
with Sal Khan of 2019, I see two
different kinds of stances
towards education, technology at
work. And over the last two
decades. One of the most
powerful stances has been the
charismatic stance, and I borrow
this term from Morgan Ames, who
did a really lovely anthropology
of the One Laptop per Child
program that was situated from
the media lab here at MIT. And
she wrote a book called the
charisma machine. And and talked
about charismatic technologists,
people who envision technology
as tools that can disrupt and
transform and rearrange existing
systems, and who imagined
futures that are brand new and
different because of new
technologies. And she contrast
that with actually sort of what
I see in Sal Khan in 2019. With
the tinkering stance that she
draws from a book from from two
historians  David Tyack, and
Larry Cuban called tinkering
towards utopia. And in the
tinkering stance, the assumption
is not that new technologies
will disrupt and transform
educational systems, but rather
that these existing conservative
complex political systems will
domesticate new technologies,
they will take new technologies
and they will slot them into
particular niches for particular
students, particular contexts,
particular subjects, and that
the future in many ways can be
seen as an extension of trends
from history that things change,
but they don't change
disruptively. They change
incrementally. They change step
by step. And in some ways the
the book failure to disrupt you
know, is like a love letter to
the tinkers or, or a passionate
plea for honoring and respecting
the work of tinker's. And that
is to say that that the
charismatic stance leads us to
sort of boom and bust hype
cycles around education
technology, in which we miss
allocate our resources. And by
contrast, there are ways that
technology can help improve
existing systems for learning.
But they tend not to be
breakthroughs, like a lot of
things in human development,
they tend to be a few steps
forward and a couple steps back
and kind of maddeningly slowly
plodding. But perhaps,
ultimately, you know, leading to
improvements, or potential
improvements in human capacity,
or at least, if we're going to
make investments in education
technology, that's the sort of
stance to bring to it. So the
first half of the book, sort of
reviews what I think is one of
the most useful disciplines for
the Tinker kind of personal
discipline, which is to start
from the assumption that any new
technology is situated in some
kind of history. And if we know
something about that history, we
can make some pretty good
guesses about how a new
technology will operate. So to
illustrate that principle, I
look at a set of technologies
that I call learning at scale,
learning environments for many,
many learners and few experts to
guide them.
Typically, education technology,
evangelists have not promoted
calculators as transformative
tools of teaching and learning.
Because there's not a sense that
calculator kind of on its own
provides a you know, a
personalized, individualized
curriculum that is scalable to
many millions of people. But
there are other technologies
we've created in which edtech
evangelists have made that
promise. And they tend to fall
into three different categories.
And you can define those
categories by who guides the
sequence of learning activities.
So there are learning
environments in which an
instructor selects the suggested
sequence of activities. And
those are things like Massive
Open Online Courses. There are
algorithm guided large scale
learning environments like
adaptive tutors, where a
computing algorithm measures
student performance on some
dimension. And on the basis of
that measure, select some new
learning activity to suggest for
a student. And there are peer
driven, peer guided network
learning communities. You know,
at MIT, I use the example of the
scratch programming language and
community where the learning
experience of scratchers is in
profound ways shaped by the
community of peers that they
interact with. On the scratch
platform, almost all of us
participate in these kinds of
networks in some way, if you're
interested in how to do makeup
on your face in new ways, or how
to style your hair, or how to
beat a level in a video game, or
how to do different kinds of
handicrafts. If you're watching
videos, posting pictures,
reading Reddit threads, you're
probably participating in one of
those kinds of networks. Each of
those three genres has a history
behind it. They tend to have
similar kinds of pedagogical
proclivities, they tend to use
similar, you know, to borrow the
terms of software developers,
sort of similar technology
stacks. So the first and the
other thing is that for most of
them, we have a kind of track
record of efficacy behind them.
As the example of Ken
Koedinger's 1997 research and
Sal Khan's 2019 proclamations
point out that, you know, we
human beings have been using
computers to try to teach other
human beings for as long as
we've had computers. This is not
a brand new field. This is a 60
year enterprise conducted with
substantial funding by super
bright people at research labs
all over the world. And so if
you find a new piece of
education technology, I argue
that you can sort of ask this
question who guides a sequence
of learning activities here, and
you can see how it sort of slots
into one of these three genres.
And if you know something about
the street three genres, you can
make a good guess about how some
new technology will shape the
future. I think I won't spend a
ton of time with this, although
we can come back to it. except
to say that, you know, for
instance, I think that
instructor guided and algorithm
guided genres of learning
technology, they tend to be
inspired by pedagogies that
emphasize direct instruction,
and experts communicating
information to novices, where by
contrast, peer guided learning
environments tend to be
interested in pedagogies of
apprenticeship, where you learn
not so much from the received
wisdom of experts, but through
the process of trying things
interacting with others sharing
your experience. In the in the
middle slot here, I indicate
some technologies that I think
are quite common to these
genres. So for instance, most
adaptive tutors, they really
have two main parts. They have
an auto grader, and the auto
grader is what allows us to
determine the level of human
performance so we can select
some other tasks. And almost all
of them, no matter how fancy
they purport to be, no matter
how many billions of cells of
data they purport to collect, no
matter how fancy you know, the
algorithms or the
parameterization they claim to
have, at their core, they almost
all use I'm variant of a
statistical toolkit called item
response theory. And item
response theory was developed by
the Educational Testing Services
in the 1980s. And I'll describe
it to you now. But I take maybe
three pages in the book to
describe it to readers, with the
point being that that this is
not intractable. This is not
impossibly complex, which is
what education technology
evangelists often try to
convince us of, like, the
fundamental building blocks of
this are well known. And they're
usually old, you know, if you
see a sort of Ed Tech roadster
coming your way, like lift up
the hood, and you will see like,
Oh, that's a pretty old engine,
or that's a pretty old chassis,
or there's some well established
pieces here. And if we
understand those well
established pieces, then we can
make some good guesses about how
a new technology will operate in
the future. Or we can identify
the pieces of a new technology
that are in fact, distinctly
new, like, it's very unlikely
that the whole thing that we've
created is going to reimagine,
you know, pedagogies, that we've
been working on for thousands of
years in our society. But maybe
they have some particularly
interesting tweak. And if you
can identify that particularly
interesting tweak, then you can
think of that as a place for
study and exploration and other
kinds of things. No, and I can
talk in more detail and do in
the book about, you know, how I
think math department head
should examine this history of
technology when making a
decision about how to implement
a new piece of math software in
their school, how a Vice Provost
for information technology might
do that, how a researcher might
identify what kinds of
interesting problems are out
there, how a designer might
think about how to approach the
development of new software.
So in the in the second half of
the book, that
what I try to tackle are,
is making clicking work
are
what I call for as yet
intractable dilemmas, for issues
that come up time. And again,
across all of these different
genres of technology, problems
that if people interested in
technology at different levels,
funders, developers,
researchers, implementers,
teachers, students, if we
thought about these problems in
in creative ways, if we were
diligent about trying to address
them, that would be our best
chance of sort of tinkering our
way to success. And they and the
problems emerge from three key
features of educational systems.
three key features of these
systems that I think are really
central to understanding why
technology doesn't lead to
disruptive society, shifting
change in education, in the way
it does in other fields. And the
first piece of the education
landscape is that education is
just immensely almost
unfathomably complex. Somewhere
today, there was a teacher, it
was a seventh grade earth
science teacher who is starting
a new unit on plate tectonics.
And somewhere else, there was a
kindergarten teacher who across
a zoom video conference was
trying to explain to students
how to open a new tab in a
browser or how to tie their
shoes. And somewhere else, there
was an advanced Mandarin class
being taught in a in a liberal
arts college somewhere else, and
you know, and then somewhere
else, there's a two year degree
program where people are
learning how to be radiology
techs, the you know, and it's
not just that those subject
areas and those contexts are
different. But what you do the
interactions you have with your
students day to day, the the
content that you cover the
skills that you address, they're
constantly changing across the
180 days of a K 12 school year
or the 28 weeks of a two
semesters of higher education.
It's extremely difficult to
think about how technologies
could be built to address all of
those kinds of diverse use
cases. And indeed, the
technologies that we have, are
very uneven. They work well in
some circumstances, but not
others for some people, but not
others, in some contexts, in
some subjects, but not others.
And I think that is one of the
you know, sort of fundamental
misunderstandings that people
often have of when they predict
sweeping changes from education
technology. They're imagining
that our technologies and I
haven't found the right metaphor
here, but they're like
bulldozers, or they're like
Swiss Army knives, they sort of
clear everything out or they do
everything. But our technologies
are not that way. They solve
very particular problems.
Typically, they're like very
specific head pegs. And the
complexity of education is just
this like manifold, huge
sweeping landscape of lots and
lots of different kinds of
holes. And then our education
system is especially here in the
United States, but certainly in
Lots of other places in the
world is shaped by profound
inequality. We provision
students in their schools and
students in their homes, very,
very different levels of
resources with which to approach
the challenge of education. And
that shapes every part of our
education system. And certainly
some of the some of the saddest
thinking and reflecting to be
done about the pandemic, is how
it is both revealed and
exacerbated those inequalities.
So I'll briefly talk about these
four dilemmas. And then maybe
I'll stop for a bit and and see
what questions or thoughts that
folks have. But here, here are
four of the kinds of things that
I think whether you're
interested in network learning
environments, or learning games,
or adaptive tutors, or MOOCs, I
think these are problems that
sort of cut across these
different kinds of approaches to
learning at scale. So one has to
do with complexity, and I call
it the curse of the familiar. If
you build a technology that is
familiar to people, you can get
that technology adopted. The
most widely used technology,
education technology, maybe in
American schools, is a tool
called Quizlet, which was
created by an MIT dropout and
and a former students of Eric's
and the terrific guy. And
Quizlet lets you generate online
flashcards. And when you glance
at the operation of the Quizlet
website, you will
instantaneously understand
what's going on, you go Oh, this
is a flashcard. Like I'm gonna
write question on one side and
answer on the other side, I'm
gonna test myself, I'm gonna
share the decks with other
people. These are flashcards
because it is instantaneously
recognizable, it can spread
very, very widely. But if we sat
down a bunch of experts in the
American education system and
said to ourselves, like, what
are the real problems that we
face here in education with
inequality? With the challenges
of the future of the labor
market? What do we really need
to work on here? I think very
few experts would come up with
the answer like, man, we really
have a dearth of flashcards out
there in the schools like we
really have to improve flashcard
access for children across the
United States. The new
flashcards are neat, but they
because they don't offer any
kind of substantial change in
the way that teachers and
students interact with one
another with the content, they
are very unlikely to lead to
substantial improvements. They
gain a certain number of
inefficiencies, and they help
students memorize some things
better. But they're, they're not
sort of unlocking new pathways
of teaching and learning. By
contrast, we do build things
that unlock new pathways to
teaching and learning. Users
often find them confusing. So if
we create things, new
technologies that incorporate
alternative pedagogies, or
create new routines or
relationships between teachers
and students, it's often the
case that this confuses teachers
and students. And these things
sometimes get passionately
adopted in small niches, but
very rarely spreading scale
across systems. In the cases in
which we do have some of our
most interesting technologies,
sort of get into schools and
start to spread and start to
change the way teaching and
learning happen, they tend to do
two things. And this is where in
the second half of the book I
tried to propose, you know, some
so not sort of pat solutions.
But some approaches to
addressing these intractable
dilemmas. They tend to be able
to be used for familiar ways
initially, and then span out
into new kinds of opportunities.
So Quizlet gets in in a very
simple way with flashcards, but
doesn't really take you anywhere
beyond flashcards. I have
colleagues who built this
graphing calculator tool called
Desmos, which is at first glance
just does everything a ti 84
calculator does on your computer
for free. But then beyond that,
there's a whole set of ways of
using this graphing software
that enables a whole different
kind of approach to teaching and
learning and mathematics. And so
it meets people in a familiar
place and takes them somewhere
else. And then the second thing
that people do when they
successfully navigate the curse
of the familiar, and this is
sort of a theme that cuts across
both the book failure to
disrupt. And a lot of my current
critiques of how we're
addressing online learning
during the pandemic, is that the
people who are good at taking
technologies and spreading them
and having new pedagogy spread
with them. They don't assume
that new ideas will travel with
the technology. They assume that
they have to engage communities
of faculty members, teachers and
learners in pedagogical
exploration about how to do new
things. So the you know, MIT
Media scratch lab, they built
scratch, but they are also in
the midst of building this giant
apparatus to teach people all
over the world. What are the
pedagogies of computational
creativity that are associated
with scratch because scratch by
itself, if you sort of drop it
into schools, it will be it will
be, you know, domesticated by
those schools for conventional
teaching and learning. But it
provides an opportunity for
allowing people to remember And
those ideas, but only if faculty
and students and communities are
supported in doing that learning
and doing that rethinking you
know, it's a, it's a way of
thinking about the scaling of
new ideas, not through
technology distribution, but
through movement making, through
community building through the
kinds of things that we see in
other forms of social movements.
A second challenge I call the
edtech, Matthew effect. And
Matthew effects are commonly
observed across sociology, they,
you know, it comes from a line
in the book of Matthew, which is
paraphrasing, like, he has much,
much more given, and he who has
little more will be taken away.
There is a persistent story in
education technology that will
have the capacity that new
technologies will democratize
education, that they will make
education more free, more fair,
more, just, my colleague, Larry
Cuban, who's an emeritus
professor at Stanford, has
marked how these arguments go
back to the days of radio is a
great book called teachers and
machines, in which he has a
picture of a bunch of young
people sitting around a radio
receiver, that's the size of a
small child, you know, one of
the big stand up units, and the
caption is, you know, with
radio, the underprivileged
school becomes a privileged one.
And you all know that radio did
not, you know, squash the
inequalities that occur between
our schools, the United States,
and nor will other technologies
that we develop on their own new
technologies disproportionately
benefit the athlete, because
those people have the financial
and social and technical capital
to take advantage of new
innovations. And it's only
through deliberate efforts at
really thinking about what would
it look like to create
technologies that close gaps
rather than spread us further
apart? through things like do
our technologies, you know, can
we measure and assess, or
observe how people from
different backgrounds and life
circumstances use technologies
differently? A tragic thing that
we're going to research over the
next year, and and learn in
different ways is that white
children in American schools and
black children in American
schools are not going to be
treated the same way on zoom,
that the behaviors of the you
know, the subjectively
inappropriate behaviors of black
students on zoom calls will be
policed in ways that they are
not for white students. And if
we don't find ways of looking at
what's happening during the
current pandemic, and looking at
it through the lens of how do
people from different
backgrounds and life
circumstances, experience
technology differently, then we
will miss the opportunity to
learn about those things and
figure out how we might be able
to address them. A third
challenge relates to unevenness,
which is the trap of routine
assessment, which is that many
of our large scale Learning
Technologies depend upon
automated assessment. And we
have some domains in which we do
really good automated assessment
and some domains where we don't
if you ask someone a question
with a well defined right
answer, computational question,
a question in a physics system
where the laws of physics are
well defined, we can build good
auto graders that evaluate those
responses from learners. One of
the fields in which we've built
the most impressive auto graders
in the field of computer
programming, where computer
science professors and teachers
can assign their students
computer programs to write that
have to meet certain engineering
challenges. And they can create
computer programs that grade
those assignments. And when you
can do that in an automatic way,
you can build systems where
people at their own pace and
time can participate learning
experiences, get some feedback
from an automated system, be
motivated and inspired by their
progress or be supported by
different kinds of feedback, and
then proceed and move forward in
their learning. There are lots
of domains we can't do this very
well, probably the most
important one is that we really
don't have good tools for
evaluating writing, for
evaluating people's ability to
reason from evidence. This is a
problem because much of what we
teach in the liberal arts
education is how to reason for
evidence. Perhaps most
problematically, the things that
we're good at building computers
to assess tend to be the kinds
of things that computers are
already good at. They're highly
structured, highly routine kinds
of problems, that arguably, we
don't really need people to do
that much anymore.
By contrast, the things where
humans have a competitive
advantage over machines in the
labor market, or sort of
equivalent contact concept in
the Civic sphere, are areas in
which we don't have very good
automated assessment. So you
know, the problem here is that
we're we're really good at
creating assessment systems for
things that we don't need people
to do anymore. And this is not
because there aren't smart
people who are working on this
problem. decades of work by
very, very smart people in
technology companies and
universities have thrown all
kinds of resources at this
challenge. And instead of
having, you know, some kind of
Moore's Law, like exponential
growth and improvement, we've
seen very, very little progress
here in decades. And I think
that should give us some
humility and caution about about
our predictions for the future
for lots of education technology
evangelist, it will, we'll make
a prediction and then when
doesn't come true, they'll say
add just we just need a little
longer. Thomas Edison in 1913,
said that by in 10 years, all
textbooks would be replaced by
the films that he was producing.
And then in 1923, he gave, I
think it was in front of the
FCC. And he made a similar
argument, except he said, Well,
actually, it's going to take 20
years, but it'll happen that all
the textbooks will be replaced
by filmstrips. And we still have
not replaced, you know, 100
years later, all of the all of
the textbooks with video
materials, because it turns out
that print is a pretty good
media for learning in a lot of
different ways. Then the last
challenge that I mapped out is
that if you're someone who's
excited about building and
improving software platforms,
you're probably very interested
in the large amounts of data
that these systems can collect.
And then the ability to rapidly
run experiments that let you
test how changes the software
platform affect people's
experiences. You know, there are
all kinds of regulatory issues
with this. And there's all kind
of, you know, sort of cultural
policy issues. There's some
sense in society, that if I go
to Amazon, to buy a book, that
they should be able to collect
some data about my experience
there. And that, you know, if I
find out that sometimes they're
doing, you know, randomized
control trials to see if I'm
more likely to buy a book with a
blue button, or a red Buy
button, that, you know, at least
I as an individual entered into
that learning experience into
that software experience,
somewhat of my own free will and
volition, not entirely. But But
as wicked as the problem is in
retail, it's much, much worse in
education. Because you know,
right now, all across the world,
young people are both compelled
to go to school. And they are
compelled to use the software
platforms that are assigned by
their teachers and school
systems. And so there are all
kinds of reasons to be very
seriously concerned, both about
the immediate risks of
surveillance in these systems,
but also about the long term,
kind of educational social risks
of normalizing and socializing
young kids to live in
surveillance cultures. There are
lots of circumstances in the
social sciences where we think
experiments are like generally
good, we tend to not intuitively
think of experimenting on young
children learning as a thing,
which is good, I think, I think
there are ways to do these
things responsibly. But I also
think that there are real
serious concerns that are that
are embedded in these practices.
And if we want to see the same
kind of improvements in learning
technologies that we've seen in
other kinds of retail software
platforms, we're gonna have to
resolve and negotiate some of
these kinds of challenges.
So that's what the second half
of the book tries to address, it
tries to chart out, you know,
the first half is really more of
a history, the second half is
more of a have an engineering
text of trying to say, Here are
four common problems that we run
into all the time. And here's
some approaches that I think
might be able to solve them.
And, um, you know, as I
reflected on, you know, what the
lessons of this, you know, in
the prologue, I mentioned that
the final copy edits of the book
were done, like March 23, the
book was written right at the
end of one era, and just at the
beginning of this new one, and a
lot of what I've done over the
last eight months is both try to
be helpful, but also try to
reflect on what do we learn from
the pandemic. That's, that's,
that's salient from history. And
I think two important lessons,
at least come through. One
constant mistake that education
technologists make is to
describe technology as sweeping
to describe it as something that
can sort of sweep away existing
systems and usher in new ones.
And instead, for a variety of
reasons, our education systems
are our conservative
institutions, because they're
extraordinarily complex. And
they're managing all these
different, competing interests.
And as a result, new
technologies tend to be
domesticated, we tend to slot
them into existing functions,
which is why we perhaps
shouldn't be surprised that all
the faculty walked away from
their lecterns and went to their
home webcams. And you can decry
that as you know, a sort of
pitiful conservatism and a
system. Or you can say, Wow,
this system is so well honed to
meet its competing interests,
that it's actually kind of found
a local maximum a local
optimization of all the
different resources and
competing constraints. And then
the second problem that I think
technology Just often make,
which is quite salient to our
moment now is that technologists
often describe education
technology as a switch that you
can flip on and on, you sort of
buy it, install it, and then it
works. And that's not at all how
education technology works.
Education technologies are only
as useful as their communities
of users are well supported and
strong. They are powerful tools
for rethinking, learning for
imagining iterative and
continuous improvements to
learning. But there's very, very
few things that we've created
that just kind of instantly in
meaningful ways benefit
learning. Rather, they become
useful. And we're seeing now all
over the world, millions of
faculty members engaged in the
process of asking themselves,
okay, I'm forced to use this new
technology now, what are what am
I doing? What am I colleagues,
my discipline, or my subject or
my school doing? And how do I
have to rethink my practice or
rethink my approach to have more
powerful, more effective, more
connecting more expired
inspiring experiences from
learning. So those those two
things of technology is
particular and domesticated by
systems rather than sweeping.
And the strength of technology
not being its instantaneous
effects, but by its ability to
be absorbed by, by community of
learners, are perhaps the two
things that I'll leave you with
before, before taking some
questions.
Scot Osterweil: And I just want
to invite everybody. If you're
up, if you're currently a
panelist, I think it's fine to
just unmute yourself and call
out at this moment.
Just be
mindful of someone who speaks up
before you. If you are a guest,
feel free to put a question in
the q&a. So I'm going to start
with a question then, because no
one else is calling out. I know,
in the beginning of my work in
educational technology, I
realized it was a fallacy. But I
had this sort of way, I guess it
was a wish, that of a technology
in my case game sort of made,
that it could somehow make
people who used it aware of
whole different models of
pedagogy, and when in fact, what
we must learn is that teachers
tend to even if they're using
something as radical for them as
a game, they're going to tend to
fall back on the same pedagogy
they've always used. Are there
exceptions that are is that as
Yeah, as Eric point yes,
mentioned the Trojan mouse that
was that was a term that he has
used? Are there no, is there no
evidence of that? Is there some
evidence of that of the
technology actually shifting the
thinking of the people who adopt
it?
Justin Reich: I mean, my view is
that there's not good evidence
of the technology, or maybe
three things, there's not good
evidence of the technology in
and of itself, shifting people's
views. A second thing that there
that there, there is good
evidence of is that technology
has an ability to catalyze
thinking about those kinds of
issues. So it's possible to you
know, you could you can go into
a group of faculty members and
say, the future is going to be
really different. The world is
changing, our learners have a
whole set of new experiences.
And as a result, we think you
should rethink your
relationships, your curriculum,
your pedagogy, all those kinds
of things. And many faculty
respond with like, No, thank
you, we're doing fine. And then
you bring a learning game into
that same community experience,
you know, or some other form of
technology. And it, you know,
operates as kind of like a
symbol of the future to be able
to say, oh, like, we could do
things really differently here.
We could, you know, this gives
us new opportunities and new
affordances new ways to rethink
things. And so I think it can
catalyze those conversations.
And then another thing that we
know is if people do move from
more familiar practices to new
practices, it's a developmental
process. You know, Judith
Sandholtz did this project in
the 1980s, called the apple
classrooms of tomorrow, where
she, with a team of folks, you
know, got some k 12 classrooms
and got a bunch of Apple two
plus computers and had wired
network with, you know, some of
the first network computing
environments and they had robots
and printers and things like
that. And she described teachers
going along a developmental
trajectory from you. Things in
more familiar ways to using
things in slightly novel ways to
doing really imagine at work.
Faculty members travel along
that continuum at different
rates.
to a limited extent, they start
in different places,
but really a lot of
them start at that first spot,
like what is the moat? You know,
how do I use this to extend
existing practices? And then I
can think about new and
different and interesting kinds
of things. So I, you know, and
that's, and that's why I think
it's so important to pair the
idea of technology integration
with the idea of Community
Learning at the same time, like,
Can games do that? Sure. But not
when games fall from the sky,
it's more likely to happen when
games arrive with a community of
people who are interested in
teaching and sharing these
ideas. I mean, Mitch Resnick has
a great line that he'd had it
with the release of scratch 3.0,
which was something like, you
know, we're gratified at how
widely scratch has spread in
schools. And we've been somewhat
surprised at how challenging
it's been not to spread the
technology of scratch, but to
spread the ideas and the
pedagogy behind scratch. And,
you know, one of the things I
admire about that group is that,
you know, rather than saying,
like, oops, disruption didn't
work, like let's go try
something else. They're like,
Okay, great, you know, let's
work in a really diligent,
devoted way on that human
development problem as well.
Scot Osterweil: I have, again,
pure Feel free to talk but I've
got some questions in the q&a.
Someone said, I very much
enjoyed large scale MOOC. What
do you see regarding the future
of this platform?
Justin Reich: So I have a
chapter about MOOCs instructor
guided learning and AI. And I
claimed that they had three big
bets, that they would provide
new pathways for different kinds
of people into higher education,
that they would unbundle and
rearrange higher education
systems. And that they would
usher in a new era of data
driven learning science. And I
think none of those things
basically has happened. I was
one of the people who's working
pretty hard on trying to usher
in a new era of data driven
learning science. And I don't
think that we've been
particularly successful. And I
think we may make incremental
progress, but I don't see like
breakthroughs on the horizon.
What ended up happening with
MOOCs is that they were
domesticated into the existing
higher education system. For the
most part. Many, I have a whole
section of that many MOOC
providers have started
describing themselves as online
program managers. These are
people who largely create
professional master's degrees in
a set of topics that are
amenable to being taught online.
And they have a familiar
business model of paying up
front for the costs, of course,
and curriculum development, and
then taking an ongoing fraction
of student tuition revenue.
After that. There are some
respects involved outsourcing
the core competencies of
universities, which is which
generally across business is
thought of as a bad idea. you
outsource your janitorial
services, you outsource your
accounting, you outsource things
that are peripheral to the core
operations. You don't outsource
teaching and learning. You know,
I think MOOCs are just a
terrific illustration of the
incredible power of education
systems, to domesticate to
incorporate new ideas. And there
are a few places where I think
there's some really neat things
happening. You know, the Georgia
Tech has an online Master's of
computer science, taught through
a series of MOOCs, which is like
7000 people at any given time
enrolled in it, you know, it'll
it'll probably end up graduating
on an annual basis 16% of the
computer science, master's
degrees, but it was not a
harbinger of a whole new set of
higher education. There was like
one particular subject area at
one particular University, which
has captured a modestly large
niche. And they'll probably be
some other, you know, accounting
degrees or data science degrees
that like, kind of work the same
way, probably not as well.
And,
and that, you know, and, and
it's, it's better to understand,
you know, I think I think the
saddest part of the MOOC story
is that there are lots of
universities that took limited
funding, and invested enormous
resources and saw very few
benefits of them, because they
weren't, you know, one of the
lucky few early adopters or
people who got things just
right, or institutions at other
places that have sort of
bottomless funds for these kinds
of things. And I still, you
know, I make MOOCs Wait, we
launched one last week called
sorting truth from fiction,
about civic online reasoning.
They're really good at teaching
already educated, already
affluent people. Some of the
already educated already
affluent ish people in society
are teachers and teachers lead
busy, complex lives and MOOCs
are a great way to reach lots of
those at relatively low marginal
cost, but that's again sort of
slotting into a particular niche
into systems in which we're
hoping to incrementally over
time improve our practice at
them, rather than arguing that,
you know, we're on the cusp of a
transformation in teacher
education.
Scot Osterweil: And I see we
have a question from Ámbar.
Ámbar Reyes: Hi, Justin. Thank
you for your I was wondering, a
question about related to
students? And what about advice
do you have for students like in
the current educational climate?
To make the most out of these
experience? Ah,
Justin Reich: right. Well, you
know, what, what, what advice do
I have for students, I had a
whole set of slides that I was
sort of clicking through, I was
talking, I just realized that I
forgot to put them up. But I
also think that sometimes it's
nice just to hear people
chatting, but I at least wanted
to have a link to the book up
there. Yeah, my advice for
students is, first of all, I
think students at all age
levels, and around the world
should celebrate all of the
resilience that they've shown,
and all of the unconventional
learning that they're doing
during this period. So I think
the most common narrative around
learners right now is like some
kind of deficit framing around
learning loss. Like, oh, man,
these kids are just not learning
all the stuff that they're
supposed to learn in the
curriculum, they're going to
fall behind. And there are very
serious issues of that. And
they're very serious inequality
issues with that. But that's not
all that happened. I think there
are lots of people around the
world who've spent this time as
part time or full time learners
who've learned all kinds of
awesome stuff, about negotiating
technologies, learners about
showing more independence and
more self directed learning. And
so I think, you know, I'm a big
fan of sort of asset approaches
to thinking about these things.
They're, they're not, there's
not a set of good sort of simple
advice along the line of study
tips that make people better
online learners. If there's one
basic one, it would be something
like, people often do, this is
true for everything. But
particularly online, people do a
better job learning things they
really care about, and they're
interested in, then people then
what they were the sort of what
you're being forced to take, you
know, if you were a freshman at
MIT right now, I would encourage
you to save some of your GIRs,
some of your required courses
that you're not that excited
about for when you come back,
and do the things that you're
just most intuitively interested
in now, because it's because
motivation is really essential
part of learning. And then a
piece, you know, that I say,
mostly the faculty, but I think
applies to students, too, is I
hope we approach this period of
pandemic learning as something
that we're all in together, I'd
really try to encourage faculty
to say like, how can you partner
with students in designing your
response to this because there's
exactly one group of Americans,
one group of people around the
world that have been learners
during a pandemic, and it's the
students who are in our
classrooms this spring and this
fall. And they know a lot that
we don't know about what good
teaching and learning in a
pandemic looks like, and we
should really listen to them. So
maybe that's a plea for you all
students to try to share that
with your faculty and to be in
those partnerships with
students.
Scot Osterweil: We do have some
questions. I can take any hands
as they shoot up? Will, you ever
Will Freudenheim: Yes, thank
you. Um, I was
wondering if the the kind of
like shifting views about time
scale that we've been
considering with the pandemic
have like changed people's
stances from either like a
charismatic stance towards like
interventions, or just like a
band aid, kind of, we're just
going to deal with it for a
couple months. And then we'll go
back to normal to more of like a
tinkering stance of you know,
maybe we're going to be in this
situation for a year more. So we
can think about like slower
kinds of experiments and other
sort of solutions that might
take a longer time to figure out
if that's something that you've
noticed, and if so, like, what
does that look like if it's
coming from educators or
technologists?
Justin Reich: Well, I'm always
amazed at the technologists
like, you know, there's some
people who just really devoted
to the charismatic stance and
like, nothing will stop them. So
there's a guy Michael Moe, who
helps run the ASU Arizona State
University's partnership with
GSV. And he had this they raised
a series of events called like
the dawn of online learning.
It's like, didn't we have the
dog 10 years ago, or 20 years
ago, like, like, you know, maybe
you don't think Dawn is like a
watershed moment in history.
Dawn is just a thing that
happens every day, early in the
morning that we all kind of
sleep through, sort of these
repeated cyclical pieces. So the
charismatics are still out
there. But the thing which is
like really taking the wind out
of charismatic sails, I think,
is that like this should have
been their moment. And I just
see, like, no hue and cry for
the kinds of large scale
learning technologies to extend
That is even surprised me. I
mean, I was at the beginning of
pandemic, I told a lot of my
colleagues at MIT, the odds that
you can, in the midst of a
pandemic, like go home and sort
of whip together a decent online
learning experience for your
students is pretty low. And
you've built a bunch of stuff
already on OpenCourseWare and an
MIT x, like just point people to
that and kind of help them out.
You know, I actually thought it
would have been more of a moment
for MOOCs and some other kinds
of things. But it turns out that
at MIT, and as far as I can
tell, in lots of other places
around the world, as well, it's
not what people wanted. There
has been nowhere that I can tech
some groundswell of students
saying, like, you know, my
introductory microeconomics
professor is doing a crappy job
teaching us intro micro online,
and I just want to be able to
take a MOOC and learn it myself.
Instead, I think what we
overwhelmingly see is like,
people really do want the
connection to their individual
professor who's like doing lousy
job managing kids in the
background, and putting together
their first online course.
Because I think that human
connections enormously
important. So I mean, you know,
the whole purpose of the book is
to try to inoculate educators
from future hype cycles to try
to convince you know, the next
time someone comes around and
says, like, Oh, it's going to be
AR or VR, it's going to be, you
know, data science, artificial
intelligence is going to change
everything is to say, well, like
that's, that's very unlikely to
happen. And they're, and they're
going to be a lot of places that
don't spend resources wisely
chasing those kinds of pursuits.
So So I mean, one of my answers,
your question is like, of
course, the tinker's are going
to win now. But that, but you
should be cautious, because
that's what I'm rooting for
anyway. Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: Mike, you wanna
go?
Mike Sugarman: Yeah, sure.
Apologies, Justin, this is a
little too heavy of a question.
But it's something I'm really
curious about. So I maybe maybe
like a charitable way to assess
why the charismatic technology
and charismatic technologists
are so successful is because
they are appealing to these
values, which are like
renewable, right? democratizing
and like fixing inequities. And
like, I think, with our mortgage
names book is so great at
showing and what your
presentation could have shown me
is like, you know, not just the
technology, you know, if you
want to fix that stuff, you have
to fix in equity and to fix
democracy and all that type of
stuff. And this is a moment
where we're kind of having this
reckoning of like, okay, there
are a lot of issues that we have
with our system set up a lot of
issues of what we expect
technology to do. And there are
a lot of issues with the people
who made a lot of money from
technology. So I guess the
question is, you know, in a
system that has previously
assigns the value of certain
technologies and education
trends to monetary value, but
they can get for investors and
nonprofits and all that. What
might creating a new set of
values or going to a more
fundamental set of values, while
dealing with this technological
space look like? Right? Like,
maybe we can't fix we can't
democratize technology with zoom
or with Khan Academy, but maybe
we still need to democratize
technology, what what might that
look like?
Justin Reich: I mean, I think
the stance that the skeptics
that I find most compelling take
his, you know, that the project
of education is like funding is
a fundamental part of civil
society, it should be
fundamentally thought of as a
public good. It should be, you
know, sort of fundamentally
democratic and therefore, you
know, accruing enormous power to
technology firms to be able to
influence these environments, no
matter how well intentioned they
are, no matter how useful their
products are. It's the wrong
people doing it. We, you know,
I, you know, I, I think I think
it matters a lot. You know, that
zoom is a piece of consumer
software, I use sold in a
publicly traded firm. And
scratch was developed in a, in a
research laboratory, at a
university and then transferred
into a non profit entity, which
is actually funded in some ways
by hedge funds and other things.
There's all kinds of problems
there. But But I, yeah, I mean,
I think that's the, you know,
what, what you're what you're
getting at is absolutely sort of
a crucial theme of the book,
which is that, you know, all of
the hard technology doesn't in
and of itself, solve all of the
hard problems. There are ways in
which technology reveals these
problems. The fact that we can't
get broadband access, we can't
get computers to, you know,
literally millions of the 57
million schoolchildren in
America is is revealing
exacerbating the same time but
revealing new kinds of
inequalities as well. So I you
know, I'm hopeful that I'm
hopeful that the moment leads
to, you know, I more than
anything else, sort of social
movements that demand that we do
more for children and their
families and our society. And I
hope that we look at them
through these lens of
technology. But the problem that
skeptics have right now, is
that, you know, like, zoom and
canvas are the only games in
town Zoom and Google Classroom
are the only games that you
can't actually critique and
resist them. Perhaps if you were
to launch a full throated
critique resistance, you know,
sort of Luddite smashing of
them, you'd be like, well, now
we're just like mailing paper
packets to kids. And that's
pretty terrible, too. I mean,
you know, to go back to this
idea, it's actually you know, in
other writing, I've sort of
contrasted skeptics and
tinkerers and, and charismatics,
and position Tinker, is, is a
middle way. And I, you know,
there's, there's a lot, there's
a lot of really good education,
technology, skepticism that's
out there. I think it is
challenged in this particular
moment, by the fact that if we
want schools to keep operating
in a reasonably functional way,
online tools, including ones
created by, you know,
monopolistic corporations are
going to be pretty central to
that. But it doesn't, you know,
I think it's part of a broader
movement in society of saying,
We will not tolerate, we should
we should not tolerate these
monopolies operating however
they want to because they're
monopolies we should regulate
them. And in some cases, we may
really should be looking at, you
know, publicly funded
alternatives to them, especially
for projects that are as close
to civil society of schools.
Does that get at some of your
issues?
Mike Sugarman: Yeah, absolutely.
That's, that's great. Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: Great, Kelly.
Kelly Wagman: Hi, um, this is
maybe also kind of a big
question. But one thing that I
wonder about is how you teach
topics related to privilege and
things like racism to people
that are, have already left
formal education. And it seems
like one way to reach people is
through technology. But I also
kind of dislike the like, Mr.
Graham sighs here's how you
learn about racism. And I'm
wondering if you have any
thoughts on that? Or if the
answer is just you have to have
individual conversations with
people in real life?
Justin Reich: No, what what,
what a great question to ask,
because there's been such a
flourishing of that, you know, I
think, you know, there are a
whole bunch of sort of, like,
white privilege syllabi by and,
you know, you know, Google Docs
and reading clubs and other
kinds of things that have been
generated in various kinds of
ways. You know, I mean, and so
of it in, in media, that's not
explicitly educational, you
know, the New York Times put out
a fabulous podcast with through
cereal called the nice white
parents, which is a terrific
five episode, you know,
investigation of those topics.
And,
you know, in that one of my
colleagues at MIT is a professor
named Peter Senge, at the MIT
loan School of Management. I
ean, he wrote this book called
he Fifth Discipline. And he
efines really successful
rganizations as learning
rganizations, as organizations
n which the process of getting
etter at things have endured in
oing your day to day jobs in
erforming the function of your
irm, you should also be
reating opportunities for all
f the actors in that firm to
earn these issues of you know,
nti racism, bias, white
upremacy, they're of keen
nterest to corporate America,
ho are generating all kinds of
earning experiences, you know,
hey're they're probably
illions of Americans who in
heir workplace, you know, are
rivileged to participate in are
ubjected to depending upon
heir point of view and the
uality of the these things,
ort of learning experiences. So
yeah, I'm, I'm quite
nterested in those kinds of
uestions. And when you, you
now, and part of the reason why
stay in education technology
s like, I just don't know, it
eems to me that all kinds of
edia are going to be central to
ddressing that challenge.
nother challenge that I'm
ersonally really interested in
ight now is people don't know
ow to search effectively
nline, and to sort truth from
iction. We, my colleague, Sam
ineburg at Stanford, has done
esearch on lots of groups,
ncluding middle school students
nd Stanford freshmen and
enured historians, who by and
arge are terrible at
dentifying misinformation and
alse hoods online. And he's
lso studied this one group of
eople, fact checkers at
restigious new organ news
rganizations who are not only
xtremely good at sorting truth
rom fiction online, but are
ike quite efficient, and use a
eries of fairly simple
echniques. So I'm interested in
his question like, you know,
here's about 3 billion people
onnected to the internet and we
eed to teach them all how to do
his. We need to teach them in
chools. We need to teach in
ibraries, we need to teach them
n their corporations, we need
o teach them in senior centers,
e need to teach them in civic
rganizations like how are we
oing to when you and when you
hink about the question from
hat scope, you're like, well,
here's gonna be some edtech in
here somewhere. Because that is
that is a huge, you know,
earning goal that we should
ave for people in our society.
hat I mean that that to me is
hat's the that's the thing for
e that keeps pulling me sort of
way from skepticism is just
his yawning need for learning
elt by billions of people
round the world, that it seems
ike we should be able to figure
ut how to use these tools to
ddress.
Scot Osterweil: Great, I have a
couple of questions in text, I
did see someone with a hand up
with them put it down. If you do
have a question as a past, if
you put your hand up, use or use
the little tool to put your hand
the virtual hands up, I'll be
able to see. But in the
meantime, let me get with these
questions from the Q&A or from
the chat. One was about you
mentioned, the technology cannot
be expected to work as a switch
that people need support from
from a community. How do you
envision this kind of community
to take place in an online
environment with MOOCs? Have you
seen any platforms today that do
a relatively good job?
Justin Reich: Yeah, you know,
the simplest answer to that
question is that MOOCs don't
provide that support. MOOCs are
good for self paced learning.
And they are, and most people
are not good at self paced
learning. And the people who are
good at self paced learning tend
to have had a formal
apprenticeship in the
educational system. And so if we
want to, you know, sort of
support community learning, we
should turn to other approaches
on technology, I think they're
neat things that have been done,
incorporate incorporating MOOCs
into, you know, community based
systems of learning to have
people take them together in
libraries, to have them built
into school systems in different
kinds of ways. But, but I think
also to like, it's important,
when we see limits, to recognize
them, and say, like, you know,
don't try to solve a problem
with a thing that's not going to
work, you know, I mean, maybe
keep working, maybe keep doing
research and experimenting in
different kinds of ways. You
know, in the MOOCs that we
create, we try to support people
in creating those community
supports and social learning
environments, by encouraging
folks to take our courses in
groups that take them in
learning circles, but we're not.
Because our our learners are
teachers, we know that they are
embedded in these social
institutions that have
mechanisms for supporting
Community Learning anyway. You
know, which is not necessarily
the case for people who want to
become computer scientists or
want to become accountants or
data scientists or other kinds
of things like that. So you
know, it's like, having having
healthy respect for the limits
of technology and saying, Oh,
that looks more like a social
problem than a technology
problem.
Scot Osterweil: Another question
is, do you see technical
innovation in means of awarding
learning credit, grades,
certificates, diplomas, you see
that as having any significant
effect?
Justin Reich: You know, the
place where I think there's been
the most discussion around this
is around some like badging and
micro credentials and things
like that. That has been an
interesting phenomenon to me,
because it's a place where
people have been able to
generate supply. And demand has
not followed, like people have
built it and others have not
come. And it strikes me as a
place where people, you know,
especially for folks who are
trying to use some form of micro
credential in a labor market,
just like fundamentally
misunderstood human behavior in
the labor market. You know,
they're saying like, what we
want to do is like, give people
who are hiring or people who are
admitting people to graduate
programs, like really granular
data about people's abilities.
And most people hiring folks do
not want really granular data
about people's abilities, they
want like very simple summaries
that allow them to go through
hundreds of resumes at the same
time. And, and by the time you
get to the sort of two or three
candidates that you really want
to go into, you don't want to
see a micro credential or badge,
you want to see like, actual
evidence of that person's
performance, which some micro
credentialing systems have. But,
you know, I think it was an
example of, you know, people
saying, like, Well, here's
something it's possible. And,
you know, if if we could change
human nature, then it would
allow all these like really kind
of interesting things to happen.
You could start sort of mixing,
matching, you know,
microcredentials, from different
places or things like that. And
it's not to say that also that,
like not all that innovation,
there are still spaces for
innovation, but also to
recognize like, there's lots of
ways the system has already done
this work. I mean, MOOC people
have have been sort of crowing
for a while about like, Oh, we
can create these sort of like
new micro credentials that are
assembled in different ways.
This is like a brand new
innovation in higher education.
But in fact, like in Britain,
in, I think the end of the 19th
century, they developed junior
colleges and community colleges.
And they invented a Greek called
the associate's degree. And that
was a kind of micro credential,
or a stackable credential that
built into another kind of
degree program. You know, and in
fact, like the heavy lifting of
inventing that happened 210
years ago, and there's, you
know, the spaces for innovation
that are left are sort of fewer
and narrower. Most of what MOOC
based degrees have done micro
masters and things like that,
they've kind of they've created
associate's degrees. But for
people who already have degrees,
they upgrade, like easier
pathways into master's degrees.
But people have master's
degrees, or for the most part
already Athlon already educated.
So again, I mean, in the courses
that I teach at MIT, especially
to undergraduates, you know, the
main thing that I try to
communicate is that developing
effective technologies requires
a rich understanding of the
social technical systems in
which they'll operate. And so
many of the false starts in
education technology are because
you have people you know, who
are really good at programming
and react or whatever else it
is. And they don't understand
complex social technical systems
very well. They don't understand
actors in educational systems
very well. And so they build
things that don't work very
well. And I mean, that's one of
the joys of sort of teaching in
in Comparative Media Studies is
just having people who take
these things very seriously.
Scot Osterweil: One more moment
for I have one last question.
From the chat. I wanted to see
what anyone else here on panels
had a question. And the question
in chat is, how could teachers
and students use technology
without being overwhelmed? in
learning and trying new things?
Justin Reich: And that's a grea
question. And I like just such
wonderful question of the mome
t. Because so many people have
een thrust in, you know, ag
inst their will, to these chal
enges. And certainly it is,
t has been some of the sources
of deepest frustratio
. I think, particularly for s
udents and families, you know, j
st feeling overwhelmed by
all of the different things
ou need to learn to participate
in school. And, you know, in no
mal times, you would say, you
know, pace yourself. Yeah, I me
n, we have all kinds of heurist
cs that we use to help people a
dress that challenge, we say t
ings like, you know, if you're
a teacher, and you're thi
king about incorporating
echnology, identify a target of
difficulty identifying an ar
a in which you're teaching somet
ing that's really important to
ou, that's really hard to teach
and where you think technology
might have some leverage. And t
rough that kind of three part r
bric, most faculty can identif
some part in their curriculum
r syllabus where like, Oh, ye
h, I'm not happy at how people
earn these things. And I bet th
re's a way of doing that better
And that, you know, that's one
athway for some people tha
gets them excited about working
on that in a way that feels mana
eable. The challenge and pandem
c times is you still have to
o that for everything all at onc
. And, you know, I mean, my, my
main piece of advice there in t
is moment, is just to, like, sh
w yourself and the other peop
e that you work with a great dea
of grace. There, there
re lots of conflicts that ar
happening between teachers an
families, between students an
teachers, between teachers
and school systems. And there b
cause, you know, we have as a c
untry have failed to manage th
pandemic. And in this, one sad
hing about that is you have lo
s of local actors getting int
conflicts over problems that
re created by by broader soci
l systems. So, you know, there
s no magic trick to
ot getting overwhelmed, pace
ourself to the degree that y
u can, you know, show yours
lf and the others around you
ome grace, and but then also rec
gnize, and this is the hopeful p
ece I keep going back to, if y
u can find one of these
oles where technology peg
its really nicely. It's
onderfully satisfying, and, and,
and builds human capacity in a
ay that if you're, if you're
atient and willing to tak
a sort of tinkerers mind f
ame and be comfortable with
continuous incremental progress
Then, you know, my colleague
en kading, er says that the ste
change is just what
0 years of incremental progress
looks like from a distance. Go
d if folks are interested in
continuing these conversations
There's a book club that we
re doing a free virtual book clu
, it's 3pm on Mondays
at failure disrupt.com slash v
rtual book club and would wel
ome any of you to drop in for on
session a lots of sessions. I
you go to the webpage. Ther
's a whole list of guests and
ther kinds of things that ar
there. If people have other qu
stions you can find me on Twitt
r at @bjfr or MIT and other fol
s know how to find me Thanks fo
some some great questions. An
thanks to Scott and Eric and
Andrew f
Scot Osterweil: Thanks very
much, Justin. And thanks,
everyone for coming. We had a
great turnout. And we look
forward to seeing as many of you
as possible next week when Jing
Wang will be presenting. So
thanks. Thanks everyone again